in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions chase
and Sara are with us hey guys how are
you hey are you
welcome welcome where do you guys live
in Dixon oh you're right here in the
Nashville area okay very cool and here
to do a debt-free scream yes sir love it
how much have you paid off paid off a
total of about $200,000 my goodness how
long did that take
just around four years okay cool and
your range of income during that time
started out about forty seventy five and
then Sarah and I got married and ended
up just about doubling so okay so about
90 now yes sir okay cool what do y'all
do for a living well I'm an engineer and
Sarah is a stay-at-home mom oh very good
okay good fun fun fun so what kind of
debt was just two hundred thousand bucks
I had 30 in student loans and Sarah had
50 in student loans and then we had 120
in a house you paid off your house yes
sir all right I'm looking at where
people way to go you two how old are you
guys I'm 29 I'm 26
oh and you're paid for house you're not
even 30 yes sir that's wacked that's
just completely crazy does it feel weird
yeah you know anybody that's 30 years
old or less than as a paid for house you
know one I know good for you guys
well done what's the house worth right
at about 120 good for you guys actually
and we actually cash flowed 20 of the
house and then we actually ended up
selling it and um there's a little bit
of a story that goes into that you sold
it yes okay so you don't have it now no
we're in a different home but it's also
paid for it okay I got you all right I'm
catching on good well done so tell me
the story what happened four years ago
that began this journey alright so and
we actually just celebrated our third
anniversary okay I'm on Wednesday and
the year before
chase met me he paid off his student
loans and then bought our first home
mm-hmm and then he met me we got married
and I added to our debt if he married me
anyway
and during the time that we were paying
off my student loans we had Samuel so I
had to pause during that and then when
we paid down my loans last year and we
started paying down aggressively on our
mortgage and then of January this year
and we went on our first family vacation
since their honeymoon mm-hmm and our son
who was 7 months old at the time
actually got sick the first day caught a
really nasty stomach virus got sick too
so we had to cut short and come home and
Samuel got better after about 3 days but
chase got worse oh so he ended up going
to the hospital for about a week and was
able to come home but never really got a
hundred percent back to normal mm-hm and
then at the end of February
he started exhibiting some of the same
symptoms so he took him back to
Vanderbilt and they admitted him for an
overnight stay the next day about noon
he got up from a nap and his back was
hurting and so he got it walked around
trying to ease the pain and nothing
really helped by 4:30 that afternoon he
was an unbearable pain and then by 6:30
he could no longer feel or move
anything's below his waist whoa so
within about two hours he became
paralyzed and so that was definitely has
affected us and yeah yeah I think yeah
Wow and he actually has lupus and a
detective spinal cord is what end of the
morning so we were at Vanderbilt for two
weeks and then went to Atlanta to do
rehab at the Shepherd Center down there
stayed there for two months came home in
May and chase was able to go back to
work and at the end of July mm-hmm and
while we were in Atlanta we started
looking for a new home that would be
more friendly to wheelchair
accessibility because our first home had
little extra room and steps to get into
the house and so we were able to find a
home and we were extremely extremely
blessed by our family our friends our
church and our community and we were
able to purchase the new home and
extensively renovate it to make Chase's
life easier from a chair so how long ago
was it again it was this February this
February
okay so this all happened this year yes
my gosh Wow now I don't I don't know
anything about lupus so is that a
permanent diagnosis or our permanent
situation then yes basically a lupus
mimics several other diseases usually
but it presents and everyone who has it
differently and it was fairly mild until
February okay all right okay so this is
your life going forward yes okay all
right cool Wow Wow I mean yeah we're
getting out of debt to what we're doing
all this oh my gosh so when did you pay
off the last debt we closed on the sale
of our first home on October 20th okay
completely debt-free and then that
turned it around and moved you into the
other house and that cleared the rest of
it yeah okay just the other day Wow so
you've had all kinds of cheerleaders in
your life but not not many of them are
really concerned about that they were
just concerned about you guys taking
care of you through all these
transitions and all this all this attack
and everything that you've been through
unbelievable and in the middle of it you
get out of that oh my gosh that's kind
of like a sidebar almost Wow Wow very
cool it was really lucky we actually had
our three-month emergency fund built up
before all this started so without that
it would have been a lot rougher and
yeah that was one less thing we had to
worry about
well money wasn't on the list of things
to worry about right then yeah yeah good
thing too
Wow Wow well I'm so sorry you guys have
been through this but obviously your
fighters and obviously you've turned
this into in situation into a positive
in your lives
so congratulations thank you absolutely
amazing Wow and Samuel is how old now 18
months all right and you brought him
with you and you brought some
cheerleaders with you who are the
cheerleaders they're my parents your
parents all right very cool are they
from the area here they actually just
moved up here Oh God okay very fun
perfect there you go well it's good to
have people on your team that's for sure
well done good job wow what a story you
guys all right it's chase and Sarah and
Samuel we've got a copy of Chris Hogan's
retire inspired book for you
and that'll be the next chapter in your
story to be millionaires and
outrageously generous along
the way you got quite a journey behind
you and quite a journey ahead of you you
guys are impressive very well done
Jason Sarah and Samuel $200,000 paid off
in four years making 47 to 90 count it
down
let's hear a debt free scream three two
one weird
thirty years old amazing
what a story you do not know what
curveballs life's gonna throw you you
just don't know when they're coming man
amazing open phones this hour as we talk
about your life and your money you know
sometimes I recoil after hearing stories
like that when someone says oh that
stuff that Dave Ramsey teaches it's
primitive it's just for broke people
that stuff Dave Ramsey teaches only
works you know if you're not
sophisticated let me tell you why if you
go through what they've been through
sophisticated isn't something you worry
about it isn't and the interesting thing
about the things that we teach having no
debt having an emergency fund in place
those things work when your life is
going well fabulously it will accelerate
your prosperity curve but those things
also work when life comes at you and
everything's not going fabulously you
heard him say his good thing we had an
emergency fund didn't you good thing
they weren't using something stupid like
a home equity loan for their emergency
fund they'd be up a creek right now
wouldn't they never read that article
and CNNMoney written by some broke
journalism student with student loan
debt coming out their ears Dave Ramsey's
an idiot you don't need to have real
cash set aside for an emergency you just
use your home equity line of credit and
yeah that's what you need though you
need to go further in debt when you have
a crisis in your family absolutely that
was sarcasm for those of you that can't
hear it yeah man the stuff we teach
works in good times and bad times
God's ways of handling money grandma's
ways of handling money common sense for
your dollars and since this is the Dave
Ramsey show hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
you
[Applause]
[Music]